y es que con él vamos a analizar en el
caso del tenista serbio novak djokovic y
quien perdió su último intento judicial
por quedarse en australia y jugar en la
australia o penal abierto de australia y
fue deportado este domingo de ese país
tres jueces del tribunal federal de
australia desestimaron por unanimidad su
apelación donde la razón del gobierno
australiano de cancelarle la visa al
serbio que había ingresado al país sin
vacunarse contra el kobe 19 fue la
principal el gobierno argumentó que el
deportista de 34 años representa una
amenaza para la salud pública el
organismo rector del tenis masculino la
atp dijo que el fallo del tribunal marca
el final de una serie de eventos muy
lamentables habrá quizás alguna razón
política detrás de esta deportación del
serbio lo hablamos con telmo languiller
el ex el ex presidente ex parlamentario
de la asamblea legislativa al estado de
victoria en australia gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
francia 24 telmo le pregunto cómo
podemos entonces analizar este caso y
cuáles son aristas más importantes según
su opinión
muy buenos días para ustedes bueno yo
creo que correctamente usted señala de
que en australia a los efectos de la
audiencia internacional estamos en plena
campaña electoral que posiblemente sea
en marzo por lo tanto y el gobierno y el
primer ministro ya tiene antecedentes en
este tema de inmigración de fronteras de
visas de hablar y utilizar un lenguaje
duro a los efectos de consolidar su base
electoral y particularmente algunos
sectores de la población
muy conservadores en esta materia yo
creo de que el gobierno tal cual han
señalado los partidos de oposición
perfectamente podría haber resuelto esta
situación antes de que djokovic y otros
tenistas llegaran a este país puesto que
hemos tenido 12 meses de anticipación
para organizar el abierto o el ahora no
tan abierto de australia que se está
jugando este exactamente ahora en esta
semana entonces telmo deteniéndose en
cuenta porque lo dejaron entrar al país
porque esperar a todo esto realmente fue
entonces una batalla política hicieron
esto digamos de cara a la selección para
el primer ministro scott morrison decir
yo soy el que mandó en este territorio
de cara a estas elecciones que vamos a
ver en australia donde busca demás
morrison su cuarto mandato consecutivo
y la oposición y el público muy
generalizado opina de que el gobierno
sabía perfectamente cuáles eran las
posturas de djokovic- en cuanto al tema
de la vacuna por lo tanto no era una
sorpresa para nosotros de que djokovic
era de una forma u otra a los efectos de
percepción o de los hechos adversos a la
vacuna por lo tanto la gran pregunta que
nos hacemos en australia es porque le
dejaron entrar en primera instancia
primero y segundo
habiendo anti habiendo experimentado el
rechazo de las autoridades de frontera
cuando djokovic intenta entrar al país
porque el gobierno federal espera una
semana entera en los circos dirían de
que estaban midiendo la la opinión
popular las redes sociales y las
encuestas para entonces definitivamente
o en última instancia intervenir todo
esto era prevenible prevenir es mejor
que curar y las autoridades federales y
diría yo también tenis australia la
situación que organiza el abierto
tendrían y podrían haber organizado este
evento muchísimo mejor y hablarle
australia y al abierto una mejor
reputación les recuerdo de que hace 11
días o 12 días que estamos concentrados
negativamente y en forma adversa al
abierto mientras que tendríamos que
haber estado promoviendo el abierto
positivamente austral y la ciudad de
mails de telmo como queda el gobierno
del primer ministro de scott morrison
tras esta decisión que dice la política
interna de australia a más también le
pregunto cómo lo registran los medios de
comunicación nacionales
bueno el gobierno ya tiene
antecedentes de haber hablado en
términos duros en cuanto a la temática
de fronteras y de inmigración yo les
recuerdo de que el año pasado y nosotros
traemos aproximadamente medio millón de
estudiantes al país miles de
latinoamericanos
miles particularmente de colombia y el
primer ministro cuando los estudiantes
no podían trabajar y no tenían para
subsidiar su bienestar semanal les dijo
si no pueden financiar su estadía
váyanse en go home los aeropuertos
estaban cerrados la economía estaba
cerrada no había posibilidad de que los
estudiantes se fuese porque lo hizo
porque lamentablemente a nivel doméstico
esto es una política que supuestamente
recoge votos especialmente en algunas
zonas donde el primer ministro lo
necesita nosotros pensamos de que a los
efectos internacionales nuestra
reputación no está bien no está buena no
es la primera instancia podríamos hablar
de otros hechos pero a nivel doméstico
le recuerdo que en las redes sociales en
las encuestas virtualmente de todos los
periódicos y canales de televisión
señalan que entre el 80 y el 90 por
ciento de la población pensaban que al
djokovic efectivamente había que
pulsarlo del país los partidos de
oposición opinan de la misma manera me
incluyo lo que sucede y el matiz que se
señala desde los sectores de oposición y
otros sectores de la sociedad civil es
que todavía hubiese sido perfectamente
prevenibles antes de que djokovic
saliese de su aeropuerto haberle dicho
si usted no está vacunado usted no entra
y podríamos haber evitado todo este
sitio completamente pues es cierto lo
que usted dice telmo también ahora el
gobierno francés que días atrás había
señalado que yo pues podría participar
en uno de sus torneos más importantes el
roland garros y en los que es más
importante del país aunque nos hubiera
vacunado rectificó el día de hoy a
través de la administrada salud francesa
y dijo que las personas que no estén
completamente vacunadas contra el cob y
1990 poder competir entonces ahora la
pregunta es esto le da pie a que más
gobiernos y organizaciones de eventos
deportivos deportivos hagan valer su uso
políticas y se siga replicando esto que
hizo australia ahora francia y decir
pues las las reglas son estas y si usted
no las cumple no juega en nuestros
torneos
nosotros pensamos que sí y no obstante
nuestra reputación en este momento no es
buena internacionalmente y ha sido muy
criticada
pensamos que eventualmente y recuerde
que tenemos el mundial del fútbol de
mujeres el año próximo en australia esto
va a ser un precedente bastante nítido y
claro para la comunidad internacional si
no está vacunado no entra y pienso que
es justo señalar lo siguiente desde el
punto de vista australiano usted sabe
que nosotros fuimos un país que estuvo
en casi permanente lockdown por meses y
meses hemos perdido gente como han
perdido otros países la población estaba
recién empezando a recuperarse
emocionalmente
psicológicamente económicamente se han
perdido miles de millones de dólares y
miles de negocios que nunca más van a
abrir y por lo tanto frente a los ojos
de la población del país era bastante
injusto de que para ser espectador en el
abierto del tenis había que estar
vacunados sin embargo había jugadores
que podían ir sin vacunarse y nosotros
pensamos que este es un precedente que
también nos sirve para otros códigos
como el fútbol como el rugby y como
otros eventos internacionales
la postura será pensemos claramente si
está vacunado y se entra a los efectos
de proteger la mayoría de la población y
si no se está vacunado entonces aquí no
está bienvenido pero eso lo podíamos y
lo deberíamos haber manejado de mejor en
nuestra opinión considerando que este
evento es un evento no improvisado sino
que sabíamos que se venía ya desde el
año pasado tenemos ya para finalizar
nuestra conversación el futuro de las
personalidades que como yo que se niega
a vacunar contra el cubil 19
nosotros pensamos de que si no se vacuna
a las puertas se van a cerrar más y más
y más el mundo está cansado de esta
pandemia la demasiada gente estamos
perdiendo en todos los países miles de
negocios costos económicos increíbles yo
creo que tenemos que convocar a la buena
voluntad y el buen sentido común de los
deportistas internacionales de cooperar
puesto que la ciencia hoy por hoy
después de todo este periodo de dos
largos años ha demostrado que las
vacunas previenen o por lo menos
minimizan el impacto de la vacuna le
hago solamente un recordatorio en este
país el 80 por ciento de las personas
que están hospitalizadas haciendo
centros de cuidados intensivos son
personas no vacunadas
actualmente y estamos teniendo en cada
uno de los estados unas 15 mil a 20 mil
personas contaminadas por día y
aproximadamente 20 personas que fallecen
por día en cada uno de los estados y el
80 por ciento de estas personas son
personas no va por lo tanto la ciencia
creemos que está dictando
de qué es lo que tienen que hacer los
gobiernos y las políticas públicas de
todos los estados